Should the US ease up on Visa requirements
for brainiacs
and other tech oriented foreigners.
One in four high tech startups in America
were founded by immigrants.
These high skilled immigrants are job makers
not job takers.
Politicians and pundits
are always talking about the importance of
high tech foreigners for the US economy.
But the fact of the matter is that low skilled
immigrants make equally vital contributions
and here are 5 reasons why.
Most Americans are not competitors of low-skilled
immigrants,
they are actually their customers.
They buy all kinds of services from them:
House cleaning services, childcare services,
landscaping services, home construction services.
If Americans can spend less on these services,
they have more money in their pocket to spend
elsewhere,
which means more jobs created elsewhere in
the economy.
The Latino and other foreign workers don't
have ties to the local community
and they don't have invested in property.
They can pick up their bags and leave at any
point to wherever they are needed.
They can go to where houses are built in Arizona
or they can go and pick fruit in Florida,
they can go wherever they want.
They "grease the wheels" of an economy, as
one economist put it.
They add to the resilience and dynamism of
the American economy.
Another way in which low skilled immigrants
help the economy
is by increasing the supply of high skilled
workers
and these high-skilled workers are called
women.
Many professional women would be forced to
spend much more time at home
taking care of their children, cleaning, doing laundry
if it were not for the presence of foreign nannies,
Korean dry cleaners or Chinese takeout.
A big fear about low-skilled immigrants
is because they are poor they impose a big
cost on the welfare state.
But the truth is that most of them
don't even qualify for most means tests benefits that Americans do.
They don't qualify for food stamps,
they don't qualify for all kinds of federal assistance programs.
So in fact they might be saving the welfare
state money rather than costing it money.
They create more jobs for Americans
because they reduce the cost of a key import
in production which is labor.
And when labor costs go down, more businesses
can form,
and when more businesses can form, there are
more jobs for everyone--including Americans.
The fact that there is somebody else to do
menial work like pulling weeds
Americans can do relatively more value added
work.
For instance, their English speaking skills
become more marketable in a diverse economy
with lots of immigrants.
These skills would have otherwise been taken
for granted
but they become much more marketable and command
a premium in the labor market.